foreign
in the NYC what's up Jasmine how we
doing
hi guys thank you for taking my call of
course what's up
um so I have a bit of a situation here I
am
I just started the I just finished
actually The Total Money Makeover book
and I'm in baby step two
um but I have a total of fifteen
thousand dollars in credit card check
um so it's not much but when you think
of my age and kind of what I'm what how
much I think I really shouldn't be in
the situation how old are you um I'm 20.
how did you rack up 15 grand in credit
card debt
I got credit cards and I did not know
how to spend correctly do you have a
bunch of cool stuff
uh yeah like well I think I I
I was in a situation where my parents
got divorced and all that stuff and I
ended up being very very independent and
I think that way to cope with a lot of
my problems with the shop ah okay so
dude listen you're the first one to ever
do that Jasmine yeah it's wild Jasmine
listen I I talk to a lot of people a lot
on my show on this show and coaching all
over the country very few people who are
twice three times your age have the
level of insight you just displayed
the idea that hey when I am stressed
when I'm trying to figure out why my
parents broke up why my dad chose them
over me like when when you can say okay
this happens in my body and then I just
start shopping if you can link those two
together which you've done you are so
far ahead of the game because now you
know okay my body feels like this when
it does that I'm gonna create some
alternative plans so that I don't hurt
future Jasmine
that makes sense yeah I just want I want
to give you some encouragement you are
way ahead of the game now he's got to
figure out how to clean this mess up and
get on the road right so continue on
Jasmine what's the question so so I
currently just transfer schools
um to a much cheaper school because I
was paying way too much and I had
student loans I'm going into the school
now going with my junior year with no
student loans
um and I'm going to continue on
um with my next year with no student
loans as well God willing
um but I still have to pay off my
student loans that are for my old school
that's 12 000.
um
I've been listening to a lot of you guys
podcasts and all that and you guys
always say like don't wait for the
government pay off your student loans
and my student loans are unable to be
touched at the moment until this until
due
um quote unquote waiting for the
government to make a decision I don't
want to gain more interest on everything
so I kind of just don't know really what
to do in terms of the order of things if
I should be tackling my credit card debt
or my student loans like I really just
kind of don't know what to do so are the
student loans broken up or is it one
giant twelve thousand dollar loan one
giant 2012 well it's broken up on Subs
but yeah in total is twelve thousand
dollars but you make individual payments
on separate loans
um the provider that I have gives me an
option to either do all or one by one
okay so it sounds like they are separate
loans and so what I would do is just
list air every single individual balance
out smallest to largest and ignore the
interest rate and you said you can't pay
on them
it's it's telling me that I don't have
to until June I don't have to because
they want you have the ability to yes
you can and put your credit cards in
there as well
okay so just basically put my loans in
inside of my whole snowball yes wherever
the credit cards fall in there so if you
have it sounds like you've got multiple
credit cards
yes okay yeah just list them all out
they'll be co-mingled in there in the
debt snowball but if you list them out
from smallest to largest and tackle each
individual balance you will feel the
progress versus staring at a mountain of
twelve thousand on a mountain of fifteen
thousand because the smallest balance is
probably a few hundred bucks maybe a
thousand bucks
yeah and now we go okay I could pay off
a thousand bucks and then you got the
next biggest one's two thousand but I
freed up that payment so I can roll that
payment plus the margin I was throwing
at it into the next one and that is how
the debt snowball has gotten so many
people to debt freedom and don't be
afraid to
like be as cheesy or as creative as you
want to be
um I was oh man it was my late 30s maybe
it's mid 30s I remember it was I was too
old to be doing what I was doing my wife
and I were paying everything off and we
just created one of those like
construction paper chains that you tear
off every time you hit a milestone you
pay off a credit card or you pay off you
know you move that number from 20 000 to
19 000 to 18 000 and we hung it in our
bedroom just so I I have to see it every
day so get creative and just begin to
knock these credit cards out and the
student loans out one after the other
after the other after the other after
the other what's your income Jasmine
okay
um I think 50k awesome 50k doing what
I'm a manager at a restaurant okay yes
I'm very I'm very blessed you can
decisions you can
knock this out in a year
right
I I hope so yes no no Jasmine if you
could you could have your 21st birthday
and oh nobody anything
okay imagine that just just imagine that
for a second
yes I definitely do and then on the day
after 20 the night of your 21st birthday
your boss says hey you got to come in
and work now it's my 21st birthday I
took off six months ago and he's like I
don't care what you did you're coming
into work and you can smile and be like
no I'm not
because you will be free right
yes thank you awesome have you watched
the FPU videos
um no I haven't I've been deciding if I
want to do that or not we decided we got
you we're gonna send you a Financial
Peace University
um because we're to welcome you to Our
Gang uh we're gonna send it to you
here's the deal you got to watch them
all and if you're really cool you can
bring a couple friends with you and
start spreading this message with them
too but we'll send you um and we're
gonna go ahead and send you every dollar
app as well as a part of this package
and you can begin to uh
um learn to manage your money as you as
you as you get better and better at
budgeting and going through all of the
lessons so hang on the line here and
Jenna will hook you up with FPU